[Música]
hola hola como estan todos ustedes lo
que me dedico actualmente es lo que se
conoce como ilusionismo psicológico esto
quiere decir que en lugar de sacar
cartas y conejos de un sombrero lo que
tratamos de sacar es pensamientos de la
mente del público de hecho alguien no te
vayas tenes el micrófono a mano venid
venid de muy fuerte aplauso nuevamente
alejandra
está embarcando porque es dónde sale una
pregunta alguna donde esté bien leído la
mente
por supuesto que no excelente al benito
villamarín hace mucho más divertidas y
colócate de este lado alejandra ok ok
la idea es la siguiente de este lado
como puedes ver tengo
una candela
y un papel
quiero que piense en este momento una
ciudad del mundo ojo no me da ninguna
indicación todavía una ciudad del mundo
que usted le gustaría de hacer a conocer
o que ya conoce y quiere regresar de
repente o que simplemente su ciudad
favorita le diga no me la diga por favor
nada parecido ni siquiera me dio una
pista cualquiera de esas tres opciones
piense en esa ciudad como ya sea que
usted la quiera conocer que ya la conoce
que su ciudad favorita o que fue hace
poco no sé ya la tengo la tiene bien
perfecto y no le voy a pedir que la
escriba acá sino nada más que se le
imaginé que la escriba o sea se imagina
que lo está escribiendo entonces por
favor agarra el papel lo puede hacer con
sus ojos porque si de repente mueve la
mano dice vio la mano esto lo importante
es como para completar el ritual piense
en esta ciudad
piense algún detalle de la ciudad y a
partir de ahora escriba lo mentalmente
así con sus ojos
el nombre de esa ciudad listo dale
de ser muy larga
doble el papel
y te voy a pedir que le prenda fuego si
siente el fuego pero no hace falta
alejandra porque no lo escribió siquiera
aparte que puede imaginarte de hacer un
incendio acá cómo se te ocurre
alessandra déjalo ahí todo bien el papel
no importa lo que importa su mente con
lo que sé de este lado que le permitan
bien a mano quiero que piense primero
que todo en la cantidad vean el rostro
todo lo que pensamos se refleja en
nuestros gestos antes que nada quiero
que me conteste si o no usted me ha
dicho a mí esa parte esa ciudad no usted
le ha dicho a alguien más esa ciudad el
día de hoy no que yo le he pagado para
que usted diga que no
por favor estamos de acuerdo estamos de
acuerdo con eso también algo importante
esto es algo que yo pueda no sé haber
pensado haber goleado o tal vez lo
escribiste en facebook o algo así o no
no he tenido tiempo no es algo que sea
reciente o algo que yo pueda conocer no
bueno
genial entonces esa palabra que tiene y
de la ciudad quiero que piense primero
que todo vean el rostro sólo vean el
rostro y analicen su reacción quiero que
piense en la cantidad de letras que
tiene
estamos de acuerdo con que no es un país
como cuba o algo así porque no es algo
corto cierto público
duró bastante de hecho creo que todavía
tiene dudas
de la cantidad del experto
lo mismo son las letras no los números
empezando por ahí la cantidad de letras
vale hay dos posibilidades de pensar los
dos idiomas o me equivoco
público vean que yo no he dicho que es
fijo lo que acabo de mencionar dije o me
equivoco pero los ojos de alejandra
demuestra que efectivamente se puede
pensar en dos idiomas cierto vale
ya veces tengo el idioma o tuviste algún
problema ahorita ya lo decidió
tal vez en el idioma que usualmente se
ve al público tal vez pensaste vean de
nuevo la reacción en español
no me digas yo no nada más pensado
no hubo reacción quiere decir que no lo
pensó en español probablemente lo pensó
en su idioma normal en la reacción
me están siguiendo así entonces tenemos
que es una palabra larga perdón sí
díganme cantidad de letras que ustedes
creen que tengan números
alguien por ahí 10
7 están 3 7 y 10
excelente
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3
son dos palabras
tranquila
imagínate que llegaste ahí
es un monumento varios monumentos si uno
de estos característicos es femenino es
un monumento
bien nada más para cerciorarme creo que
lo tengo pero bueno son muchas las
posibilidades y no sé qué tipo de
personas y alejandra levanten poquito el
mentón de esta forma así y va a gritar
sin abrir la boca va a gritar el nombre
en su mente a la cuenta de 31 en su
mente sin hablar dos no todavía no pero
diga tres gritan uno dos tres
1 2 3 new york
decime algo se tiene que llevarme
demonio fuerte aplauso alejandra muy
bien tranquila relájese
ok estudiar música sabemos que
desarrolla la memoria estudiar teatro
nos desarrolla también las habilidades
sociales pero qué habilidades se
desarrollan cuando alguien estudia
ilusionismo hoy les voy a hablar así
rápidamente tres habilidades que se
desarrollan al estudiar este bello arte
la habilidad número uno es el gusto así
como se llama la conferencia es el gusto
que desarrollamos por lo imposible
usualmente las personas cuando escuchan
esa palabra imposible sienten que hasta
ahí llegó
no hay más cuando alguien le dice no
esto es imposible ya se acabó la
historia pero en el caso de los
ilusionistas se nos pasa totalmente lo
contrario cada vez que alguien dice
imposible ahí comienza todo lo mejor la
mejor forma de demostrar esto sería una
reunión de magos de ilusionistas si
alguno de los que asisten dice algo como
bueno me gustaría hacer algo como esto
pero es imposible
a partir de ahí les puedo asegurar que
todos van a comenzar a decir todas ideas
y formas para lograr ese imposible para
el ilusionista el imposible es el inicio
entonces se desarrolla un gusto muy
especial por todo lo que parece ser
imposible se vuelve una especie de reto
la habilidad número 2 es un poco extraña
pero de la habilidad que desarrollamos
para proponer soluciones ridículas
sé que suena raro pero es muy importante
que las soluciones en el ilusionismo
sean ridículas porque porque si yo digo
algo que lógico para el público también
va a ser lógico de manera que esa
solución que se me ocurre para lograr
esa ilusión al público probablemente
también se le va a ocurrir por eso
cuando estamos nuevamente una velada de
ilusionistas de magos vamos a escuchar
cosas sumamente absurdas por eso cuando
de repente nos revelan un truco uno dice
por dios no puedo creer que sea esa
tontería porque para nosotros esas
tonterías es algo común es algo
constante y les aseguro que a nivel
creativo es sumamente potente el no
tener miedo de pensar en soluciones
ridículas es sumamente potente no
solamente sirve en el ilusionismo sino
que sirve en el resto de las cosas en la
vida cotidiana y los números el número
tres la habilidad número tres es muy
curiosa es muy extraña también y es la
habilidad
lograr predecir tal vez o intuir lo que
el público está pensando los
ilusionistas de una u otra forma estamos
ciegos ante lo que está pasando no
sabemos cómo el público va a recibir lo
que estamos mostrando para nosotros es
una cosa pero para ellos va a ser otra
cosa porque porque la magia no pasa en
el escenario en las manos del mago la
magia pasa en la mente del público ese
es el verdadero objetivo llegar a la
mente del público ahí es donde está el
lienzo donde queremos dejar recuerdos
por eso es muy importante para nosotros
tratar de intuir y tener esa capacidad
saber que lo que el otro está pensando
sabemos que nuestra realidad es
independiente a la de los demás y eso es
muy importante en la vida cotidiana por
ejemplo
un ejemplo de estas tres habilidades
tengo por acá una abuelita esto es más
un acto clásico de ilusionismo sino
mentalismo no hay que leer la mente de
nadie más o menos sino que más bien es
clásico si yo le digo ustedes que tienen
que desaparecer un objeto como este la
mayoría de personas diría nada es
imposible no se puede imagínate con
tanta gente viéndote jamás pero para las
elecciones estás es como si claro me
encanta quiero lograrlo
bien
ya saben lo que voy a hacer lo segundo
que van a hacer es buscar ideas absurdas
entre más absurda es mejor y una de
tantas lo consiguen
pero el punto número 13 es tratar de
predecir lo que el público está pensando
y yo sé que ustedes
un 99 por ciento está pensando que la
bolita realmente la dejé en esta mano
cierto
y es cierto
por eso es tan importante saber intuir
cuando el público reacciona o algo
pero por el contrario si de repente uno
utiliza algún distractor algo que
distraiga
el efecto es más sorprendente gracias
no no no no no gracias todavía de una
cantidad de personas que continúa
siguiendo mis movimientos si algunos si
se dejan ir y les parece increíble pero
hay algunos cuantos que no esta vez voy
a hacerlo de nuevo vamos todos síganme
pero hagan lo que hagan
no olviden que yo también los estoy
siguiendo
si aca
mano vacía
está vacía
cuando ya sabes exactamente qué es lo
que la gente está buscando está pensando
es mucho más fácil
busca la forma de cambiar
en el momento
necesario
hoy hicimos un experimento social con
algunas de las personas que asistieron y
esto fue lo que logramos un experimento
y relacionado aprender ilusionismo
[Música]
es invisible
gracias
[Música]
tantos
pero en el 15
[Música]
no lo miré desde luego
más cuerpos más y cantantes de hombres
más personas premios
la verdad
sabes la vela
efe
[Música]
para mí él viene con
sí
[Música]
el poder de rosas
ya saben desarrollen un gusto por lo
imposible no tengan miedo a decir todo
tipo de soluciones ridículas y cuidado
con lo que creen real porque
probablemente en la ilusión de otra
persona muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]